I just think a lot of women are all in  their emotions they say they want one  thing but they really want another and I  agree with Andrew when he says women  don't know what they want women think  they want a nice guy they don't want a  nice guy that end up walking all over  him and disrespecting him 90 of women  May hate Andrew but I think would like a  man like Andrew I think women are more  emotional so like yes if you see a video  of Andrew saying something which is  Harsh and naturally exaggerated for  marketing purposes it's gonna trigger an  emotion in you and then I think it takes  um from my experience either more time  or a man around you to say hang on Leia  like why don't you look at it from this  perspective you know and you can  actually see the logic and then you're  like oh yeah okay actually that makes  sense so I think women naturally are  gonna not like him because we are  emotional